i've heard about your book i don't
remember exactly where i heard about
your book master and it's emissary and i
believe i even came to watch the film
version of it maybe one of the first
screenings of it where you had some
laptop trouble
and you were skyping live to us the
movie was was okay but the book the
movie doesn't sell the book the book is
a fascinating fascinating it's a it's
it's a frightening
book at least
i find it to be so i find it to be
unnerving and subversive we can talk
about why i find it
to be that later this channel is about
theories of everything and
usually that involves talking to
physicists string theories included and
so on and so on but
the way that i conceptualize the theory
of everything is there's no
english word for it there's a german
word it's called veltan
that means a framework through which to
interpret the world
it's like it's more than a world view a
world view would be not selling it
properly and i believe you have a i
believe you have a veltan xiaong
and it's yes
it's
well
i don't know how you did it i also
i also have a gaza tale here
what's that
a theory of
everything okay well this is a great
time to give the audience a quick
recapitulation of your main thesis of
the master and its emissary
yes
effectively
people think
that they noticed there was a difference
between the two halves of the brain
in the late 19th century
and then this took a step forward in the
1960s and 70s with the first split brain
operations
in
[Music]
california
in which people's brains were surgically
severed in the middle the connection
between the two halves of the bearing
the corpus callosum was severed
and so it was possible to interrogate
and to investigate one hemisphere at a
time and a number of theories arose out
of that
and most of them are now considered
wrong and
correctly they're considered wrong
but
the problem that we have to
rather different hemispheres doesn't go
away
why
if the brain
gets its power from making connections
should be an enormous divide right down
the middle of it
and this is not just for humans this is
for all animals to be studied they all
have an asymmetrical
neuronal network with some kind of
division between the parts so
i set about investigating that
and
it occurred to me that what was
the difference was the need to pay
attention
to the world in two different ways at
once
and that's a very important point
because how we attend to things changes
what we find
not just whether we're aware of them but
the quality of the awareness changes
what it is that we find there and it
also changes us who are doing the
finding
so
attention is a moral act it creates or
destroys
different ways they will bring into
being two different
versions if you like of reality
and
i then started investigating 20 30 years
what these differences were
and effectively they aren't what people
used to say they used to think it was
you know as you think of a machine well
what does it do well the left hemisphere
does language and reason and the right
hemisphere does pictures and emotion but
this is not right since all these things
are looked after by both hemispheres but
we should have asked a different
question if we'd been thinking in terms
of a living being instead of a machine
instead of asking what does it do so
it's just a functional utility we'd ask
in what manner
how does it do it and to what sort of
end because
things evolve in
[Music]
in in living beings in ways that answer
to
existential needs to being able to carry
on being
so
and i think there is an answer to that
that we do need in order to
um be able to pay attention to little
details of things which is mainly things
that we're going to use like food or
you know if you're a bird picking up a
twig to build a nest or
catching your prey
you need a certain kind of attention
that doesn't really need to know the
whole picture it just needs to know the
little tiny bit in the middle of the
picture which is very highly focused on
but if it's only paying that kind of
attention it will not survive because it
will become prey to another creature
very quickly so it needs to have a
different attention which is a broad
open attention
and a sustained attention
now that that's a very you know
a very brief remark but it uh on it
hangs just about everything because
because these two ways of attending
bring about two different
veltan xiaomin they bring about two
different ways of looking at the world
in one
there are things that we can use and
they're essentially fragmented one from
another we can pick them up they're
isolated we put them together to make
things that we want
and it has no meaning and it's not
really connected to us but we can
manipulate it and that's the left
hemispheres picture the left hemisphere
enables us to manipulate the world and
in survival terms that's obviously very
important
but it doesn't help us understand the
world at all
the right hemisphere mean time which
doesn't usually have access to speech it
contributes to language but it
for most of us doesn't actually speak
is seeing a completely different world
one in which things are
never entirely isolated or atomistic
they're interconnected they are
in fact everything is connected to
everything else ultimately
and it's a field that is changing all
the time it's not just made up of things
that sit in the field
it's the whole field of things that we
see and perceive and we relate to it we
don't sort of see it as a thing and then
relate to it it comes into being through
our relationship with it
so that built into it is the idea of
relation
and so this is a very very different
world and it sees things as
special unique
that's
that's a thing we might come back to
because people might say but surely if
they're unique then
what's this about them being all
interconnected but it seems to me the
whole business is to be able to maintain
together
uniqueness and individuation with
togetherness without collapsing into
fragmentation and
atomism
so it sees a world made up of unique
individuals that that are constantly
changing it sees all the stuff that's
implicit left hemisphere understand only
understands the most explicit stuff
this is the world that we live in every
day nowadays
it's
nobody picks up the messages and if you
do they become something quite different
try explaining a joke try explaining a
poem try explaining a piece of music you
can't because it is an experience in
which all the important stuff is
implicit and so of course is
the whole realm of
what we seem to have completely
abandoned the idea of the being
a sacred
world a divine element in the cosmos
these things don't make sense to the
left hemisphere it seems obviously a
mistake
but
that's because it hasn't seen so much of
the picture anyway i'll leave it there
and you can ask me some questions